[Music]
let's help you guys here in Kiev Ukraine
this video is about the corona virus
situation in the city in the country now
if you here for scholarly data watch no
further but if you want to see what it's
like on the street is how it feels how
it looks
that's the video I got for you so what
we're gonna do is walk around a bit go
into the Metro pop out a few different
neighborhoods one being a shopping area
one the busiest street of the city and
then also end up at a let's just say a
beautiful surprise location at the end
and so you can see nobody really has a
mask on the few that deal are coming out
of the Metro because that is mandatory
at this time it's funny how it's changed
like about a month ago
Joey's wearing this outside not so much
you can see
put down these markers for social
distancing
just the weekend nobody's in here zeros
Oh No
we're here to Belmont station
Oh but it delays the chain gang
you can see the the I don't know what
your car looks like a ping-pong
it is a ping-pong paddle
mooshka that runs there
these controls
they're switching up so in all these
metros you have
I think it's administrator and she's
looking at it she's looking at us
because there's still some times that
Soviet programming some of the older
people especially stations where cameras
weren't allowed here back in the day so
they say the cases the cases have spiked
I don't know what the definition of
spiked is context so there are over
thousand people that have died in
Ukraine thousand have died in Ukraine
across the whole country so the numbers
are like relatively love for the
population but there was the biggest
increase cases yesterday so it's opened
up a lot but things are starting to
tighten up a little bit for example the
little store near my apartment we could
go in without mass for long nobody's
wearing a mask now they won't let you
purchase anything without a mask and
because the fines the fines are 17,000
for an individual so if I go in and make
a purchase I don't have a mask on 17,000
grivna that's like I think it's roughly
six six hundred forty dollars and then
the store get this one the store gets a
three hundred I think it's a three
hundred and forty thousand grivna fine
which is like what is that that's like
twelve thousand dollars or something I
don't know something around there crazy
amounts here we are outside Gulliver
shopping law
[Music]
so you get a temperature check doing in
any shopping establishment I think it's
any shopping establishment now not the
magazines the little stores but like
grocery stores or shopping malls that
sort of thing everyone's got to wear a
mask in here
and I got to say people are complying
quite well
but even though we got in past the front
door there's another check here
[Music]
as far as the social distancing goes
gotta say that's falling apart quite a
bit
when say anyone's social distancing
anymore
so seems quite normal normal supermarket
someone's mashed up the workers had
these space masks these shield it's a
very cool confusion of a restaurant
restaurant options and a grocery store
big big wine splash
that restaurant life is back in full
swing
indoors is happening now
[Music]
so when this thing started my wife and I
were in Portugal we spent our winter in
Portugal but where we're based out of
Kiev
so the president gave like a 48-hour
warning to get back into the country so
we got back very quickly cut the trip
short and that first week I'm not gonna
say panic but it was definitely like
okay let's go to the basics here get a
lot of beans pull money from the ATM
there was a week where you couldn't get
dollars in the country and so I think it
was for most people right they're
worried about what's tomorrow right the
US had the toilet-paper crisis and to
that I just want to say get a bum gun
use water to clean everything else and
best in a bum gun so things locked down
the metro closed got really quiet on
these streets like nobody out here very
few cars anyone that was out had a mask
on then they they closed the parks or so
they they said they closed the parks but
nobody really
followed the rules with that one and so
there's a nice period hair is very quiet
nobody out no metro no transportation
and then slowly it's it's been awakening
and it's been an awakening and now the
interesting thing is now is the risk is
time to be out if you believe the
science
and nobody's really worried anymore
including myself
nobody knows what's going on really
people were worried about the Khedive
know following its 26.5 five to the USD
which is actually quite good so when
this thing started everyone was trying
to get as many dollars as possible
wearing that currency was gonna go in
the toilet but it did it was like
actually got stronger all my favorite
drummer this guy's awesome
[Music]
this guy just sets up his kit all over
the city every day of the year maybe not
every day but all times of the year he's
out there in the coldest winter days all
by himself
loves his battalion
that's what I love about the city it's
unfortunate
proper motley mix a little bit of
everything
Soviet architecture new architecture
decaying apartment block Italian the
drumkit all sorts of random stuff you
see here
[Music]
I'll do many more videos on the city but
right here this is this is my Don this
is where the fighting was happy this is
where citizens were going up the hill
towards Parliament and soldiers were
firing on them
you have to respect the Ukrainians for
their ability to spend time just chillin
hanging out at the bridge over the Dini
put off river
go to Hani violent it's actually a face
full of nature a huge beach here and if
I jump in the water but it's nice the
best reparation let's go down there so
the street performer thing this just
started to come back
[Music]
[Applause]
about here bridges Wow
so when this thing first started we'll
ride my bike over this bridge there'd be
a few people and he'd want like 20 feet
from the next guy everyone was super
paranoid there's like this paranoid
energy in the air
that's gone that's for sure
George don't do my virus
boskie boskie biscuit
yes gobias knocking every sir - Allen
even hope not
and that's how it's done
so guys not a scientific assessment of
what things are like here in Keefe but
hey that's what it's like walking around
so
it was actually a lot in that because if
this thing is the real if it is the real
deal we're all highly contagious then
should be interesting here in a month so
that's the end of the the end of the
coronavirus situation tour and keep a
lot of boats out today and I'm gonna be
doing I'm gonna be doing a bunch more
videos on Ukraine because I'm here and
I'm not going anywhere and if your
babushka they do she wants to watch
they'll be Ukrainian subtitles in all of
them so thanks for coming along on that
journey until next one
[Music]